as this iconic series comes to a close I
think it fit to talk a little about the
inspiration of the series title namely
the Dark Soul as the final and most
mysterious of the four Great Lord Souls
the Dark Soul has been a topic of great
intrigue thought and discussion its
first master the furtive pygmy is also
one of the game's more obscure
characters a beam we know little about
who one day hope that others descendants
would rise up a Dark Lord to end age of
fire and usher in the new age of dark
this last DLC is playing heavily into
the theme of the Dark Soul and the
furtive pygmy descendants the ring city
is a traditional city for the big news
its Sun is blotted out gaining the
appearance of the dark sign the
signifier of an accursed at Undead these
two attributes connected the city
command as mankind is descended from the
first signi and we all should be
familiar with the dark sign that has
accompanied us in all of our adventures
to the series undead men and women these
with the heavy theme of blonde or the
land of hollows adds up to a big focus
on introspection it seems that we'll be
taking a look inwards and learning more
about who we played as these past three
games in this DLC another point I think
would be unwise overlooked is the Rings
night shown dauntingly in one of the
promotional images and the gameplay
trailer it's given the description a
ring night who's one of the old the
withered sword which was sealed by the
gods in the past seems to have regained
his past appearance during night bears
on its chest a gaping hole resembling
the dark side another connection the
night approaches the player brandishing
a mighty sword of fire tilted with a
dragon so powerful that it struck enough
fear into the mighty God as they sealed
the sword away alongside this sort of
fire the night wheels a powerful dragon
face shield that is capable of
multi-directional waves of flame which
provide ample cover for the ring night
to strike the ring night obviously has
its share of Dragon imagery this is
amazingly important to note considering
that the gods greatest threat was the
dragon they feared the wing in
everlasting be a men
as they had to fight to the death
against these these to secure their
lives as leaders of the world the gods
also happened to fear this nice weapon
of choice the death of this connection
is one of utmost importance perhaps the
ring night simply adopted what it saw is
powerful the dragons are an easy picture
of this however we know that from salts
almost always plays into the deeper side
of things at least a little more than
that could the ring nights have been
like the nameless King siding with the
Dragons against the gods this could be
reinforced by seeing the ring city not
as a gift from the gods to the pygmy as
some form of shelter but instead a curse
a place of Exile for the group that
caused the gods so much additional fear
being the house of a power that rivaled
their own the Lord soul if this is so
the ring night siding with the Dragons
definitely becomes plausible another
important feature to know about this
peculiar and intimidating night these
similarities to zoos are cray we noticed
the dark rapes were men corrupted by the
bit so maybe something similar to be
said of the ring night they could
possibly be some of the Knights of old
or even some of the pygmies that dwelled
within the ring City corrupted by
something not necessarily the abyss like
the dark race or perhaps they were
corrupted by the abyss and is an
additional something else in either of
the previous two cases or even a mix of
both the ring night is a flow of utmost
importance I think that there will be
much to learn about ourselves and our
existence or our characters existing by
looking at the ring night it may be able
to provide insight about the dark side
Dark Souls the furtive pygmy how men can
be corrupted and the new age whatever
that may be that seems to be descending
upon us the ring night could have been
just another enemy with his gaping chest
whole dragging weaponry and dark race
harkening armor I can't see that
happening this last DLC is the final
note of the epic symphony that is our
slope
it's the closer and the finale as we
learn about the age of dark the furtive
pygmy and descended lon door hollows the
ring night the dark sign the age old
dragon andaba dark souls will all be
tied up in this one piece of time I look
forward to meeting the rig night and all
of competitors on this final field of
battle